>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Good morning and
happy anniversary.
This is the 10th year.
[ Applause ]
>> The 10th year of the National
Book Festival and it is people
like you, book lovers and people who
love to come and meet authors who--
and aren't afraid to show it,
who make this great
institution possible.
Before we begin, I
want to inform you
that the pavilion's presentations
are being filmed for the Library
of Congress, for the website
and for their archives.
So, if you step up
and ask a question,
you are going down in history.
I want you to be aware
of that [laughter].
And please don't sit
on the camera risers
and turn off your cellphones
if you would.
Thank you.
I am Marie Arana.
I am a writer at large for The
Washington Post and I'm here
to introduce your host,
Dr. James Billington
who has been the United
States Librarian of Congress
for 23 marvelously productive years.
[ Applause ]
>> He is only the 13th
person to hold the position
since the library was
established 210 years ago.
Think about that.
There have been 43 presidents
from John Adams to Barrack Obama
but there have only
been 13 librarians
of Congress during that time.
Dr. Billington's accomplishments
are legend and legendary.
Allow me to mention a few.
He is the force behind the Librarian
National Digital Library Program
which makes available
online, millions and millions
of publications from the
Library of Congress as well
as from other libraries and research
institutions around the globe.
He created the James Madison
Council whose members helped govern
and shape the important
work that the library does.
He is the founder of the John W.
Kluge Center, a haven for scholars
around the world who
produce a wider array
of ground-breaking scholarship.
He's established unprecedented
exchange programs with Russia
which is in fact, his
personal field of scholarship.
But in truth, he's built bridges
with regions all around the world.
Perhaps, most important at least
today on the 10th anniversary
of this magnificent
living institution,
Dr. Billington is the mastermind
behind the National Book Festival
along with Laura Bush and this
festival as you well know,
is one the great public
celebrations of books
and reading in this country.
It's a great honor to
introduce a national treasure,
the director of the National Book
Festival and the US Librarian
of Congress, Dr. James Billington.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much
Marie and welcome.
Welcome to you all for this 10th
Annual National Book Festival
for our opening ceremonies and
this is a milestone anniversary
of what we have been calling a
decade of words and wonder dedicated
to the celebration of books,
reading to literacy and libraries,
and above all, to the wonderful
experience of one author speaking
to one individual,
individuals of all ages.
We thank you for being here and let
me just say a word of special thanks
to Marie Arana who does
such a wonderful special
job of introducing--
[ Applause ]
>> Supported by our honorary chairs,
President Obama and Michelle Obama
and organized by the
library, the wonderful staff,
all these shirts you see
with National Book Festival,
these are Library of Congress
volunteers of their own time.
They're not getting overtime for
this but they want to be here
because this is a corporate
expression of your library,
The National Library, a
commitment to all of these
and libraries everywhere.
As we bring up the curtain.
[ Applause ]
>. As we bring up the curtain
on this very happy occasion,
we realize that there will be you
adults here in this very audience
and throughout the day
who have virtually grown
up with the National Books Festival.
The offerings here are so varied.
Our authors so diverse and skilled
that it's possible to come back year
after a year, not only not
have the same experience twice
but to find some new forum
of enrichment as well as fun
because this is an
enjoyable festive atmosphere.
It's a festival not a grim
duty and it's just great
to see you all here on a clear day.
We've welcomed so far over the
decade about a million book lovers
of all ages to the National
Book Festival and this year,
the festival has a
particularly international flavor.
On our stages today, we have
several authors from variety
of nations who've won prestigious
international awards including the
Noble Prize for literature, we
welcome them all and we await
to hear their stories
with great interest.
Everybody loves a good
story, stories unify people,
theories tend to divide them.
America's a pretty great
story composed of a lot
of individual stories and our
authors today span the globe
as well as our own nation.
So, it's a distinct privilege
to introduce our opening author,
Isabel Allende who is
known throughout the world,
is a best selling Chilean-American
writer,
born in Lima where her father
was a Chilean Ambassador.
Her uncle is Chilean
President, Salvador Allende,
who was assassinated in
a military coup in 1973.
Believing it unsafe to remain in
Chile, under those conditions,
Isabel and her husband and two
children fled to Venezuela.
While in exile, she wrote her first
novel, The House of the Spirits,
which was made into a film in 1994.
Her works weave wonderful elements
of that special quality of writers
in our neighbors to the South.
In this hemisphere,
the magical-realism
which she's helped bring to us
and which often depicts women
and their struggles with
particular sensitivity.
She has written many
novels and other works,
such as plays and children's
stories.
Her most recent novel is The Island
Beneath the Sea, Harper Collins.
Following this morning's
presentation,
she will receive this year's Library
of Congress National Book Festival
Creative Achievement Award.
Sorry, that's a lot of words.
[ Applause ]
>> That's a lot of words but
she has such a universal range
and such wonderful sense of humor
and humanity that we wouldn't work
on reducing the name of that
prize in her honor to an acronym.
Ladies and gentlemen, Isabel Allende
who will be interviewed this morning
by author and Washington
Post writer Marie Arana
and then she will be
followed by Dr. Deanna Marcum,
the head of this year's Library of
Congress Team for the Book Festival
who will present this special
non-acronym even if a little long
in truth but short in wonderful
expression of direct feeling
of gratitude for her giving
this international flavor.
She is an American citizen who
we're very proud of and proud
to give this award to and
once again, welcome to you all
and welcome to your families,
your friends, and everyone else
that can help make this
a really festive evening.
Ladies and gentlemen, now, Marie--
and no, one last word
[audience laughter].
This is not just the
10th anniversary
of what we've already
done but we have,
thanks to a very special
donor the assurance
of another five years
not just next year.
[ Applause ]
>> So. So, please give a
special round of applause
to our special donor, a great
friend of things in this city
that are important to the country
as a whole, David Robinson.
Please take a bow, sir.
[ Applause ]
>> And now, that wonderful
and amazing spirit Marie
Arana and Isabel Allende.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Is this thing working?
>> Oh good.
Okay. Well, Isabel Allende is
obviously very well known to you.
And she has been beloved to you.
She's been translated into 30
languages, sold 60 million copies
of her books around the world.
>> Where is the money?
[ Laughter ]
>> She is read everywhere
from Rio de Janeiro to Tokyo
and what people don't know is
what you are going to discover
as I've discovered over these
15 years of knowing Isabel is
that she is apart from being
this unbelievable work horse
who works 10 hours a day and gets
up at 6:15, works 10 hours a day.
Starts every book on
January 8th [laughter].
Works round the clock.
Apart from that, she is a remarkably
warm wonderful human being and I am
so glad to have her here.
Thank you for coming to the
festival right at the top.
>> Thank you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay. Let's start
with present history.
The Island Beneath the Sea.
You've written a very stirring
book about Haitian woman,
a slave mulatto, who survives the
violent Haitian revolution barely
and comes to New Orleans at the
turn of the century, 19th century.
Clearly, you chose the subject
before Haitian earthquake happened
possibly before hurricane Katrina.
What led you to it?
Tell us about that.
>> Well actually, I wasn't
planning to write about a slave.
I was planning to write
about New Orleans,
the city that is just
fascinating, very different
from all the other
cities in this country.
And probably unique in the world
and much of its flavor comes
from 10,000 French white colonizers
that escaped the slave revolt
in what is today, Haiti.
And they went to New Orleans
where they bought land
and they established themselves.
They came with their
white families of course
but they also brought some
domestic slaves that they trusted.
Slavery was not abolished
at that time
in the United States but trade was.
So, you couldn't bring slaves
from abroad but the pirates
of the Caribbean were
selling slaves.
So, this input of Africans into
the country was very important
in this city and there was a
large population of free people,
of color with their own
culture, with their cuisine,
with their music, and that's what
has given that city its flavor.
>> Now it's a very intriguing
title which I'm not sure.
I've read the book
but I don't remember
that you actually really explicitly
explained the island beneath
the sea.
Tell us about that.
That's a marvelous lyrical title?
>> Well, the slaves that we're
kidnapped and sold in Africa came
from different places in Africa.
They had different
religions, different languages,
and different ethnicities.
They we're not homogenous
at all and one of the things
that the slave traders
did was separate people
from the same village
or the same family
because when people are
together, they are empowered
and so they would separate
them and sell them separately.
However, in Haiti, they developed
a sort of bastardized French mixed
with African words that became
Creole, the language they spoke.
They communicated with
the drums and they had
in common a spiritual
belief that we call voodoo.
And it is a mixture of, there
were many Muslims also that came
as slaves and animists
and different religions
and they created this religion
that was extraordinary.
They believed in one god only.
You cannot reach that god.
It's too far away but
there are the loas who--
who are like the saints
in the Catholic Church
and the loas have different
functions in the spiritual world.
There's one for day,
one for love, et cetera.
And during the ceremonies in trance,
the practitioner would be mounted
by the Loa and become the
Loa and they would have--
these people who had no power,
no control of their lives at all.
They would have the
experience of the divine.
The experience and the
power of the divine
and that empowerment allowed them
to face the troops of Napoleon
which where the best trained
troops in Europe and defeat them.
They believed that for every
man or woman that was fighting,
10,000 souls had risen from
the island beneath the sea
to fight with them.
The island beneath the sea
was paradise, [inaudible],
the place where your
soul went when you died
and so that's the title of the book.
>> Now, a few people realize
as Isabel so clearly describes
in this book the incredibly
bloody revolution
at the Haitian revolution was.
It was a roiling time.
Everything was burned to the
ground and for a long time,
Haiti was ignored by the world.
This is a really quite amazing
bit of history which affected
of course Louisiana and New
Orleans because in the way
that Cubans have created and defined
Miami, the French from Haiti,
the white overlords and the
black slaves define Louisiana.
Tell us about your
research for this.
How did that started?
How did you conduct it?
>> Well, first, I want to say
that this is a book about a slave
and the subject of slavery is of
course very important in the book
but it's really a human story.
It is not awful to read.
It's actually, I think,
very entertaining
so please buy it [laughter].
Yeah. What was the
question [laughter]?
>> How did you research
this incredibly entertaining
novel [laughter]?
>> Well, plagiarizing of course
because that's what you
do when you research.
First, you read the history books
but the history books are written
by the white men and they're
always written by the winners.
You never hear the voices
of the people of color,
the losers, the victims, the women.
You never know how people really
lived and so then there is,
correspondence, memoirs,
the libraries who can provide
wonderful stuff of course
and the rest also is a
little bit of imagination
because once you have the time
and the place researched
then you write about people.
It's their stories and
people are the same.
We tend to think that people who had
lived before us were simple minded.
No they didn't have the technology
maybe but they were just as complex
and if you read any of the letters
or the documents at that time,
even written by slaves
like [inaudible].
They're extraordinary
pieces of literature.
People had really a very
sophisticated way of writing
and thinking and living and so
just imagining how they would
behave today.
I can write about what happened
then because people are the same.
We all feel the same
and we felt the same
and we felt the same 200 years ago.
>> There's nobody who makes
that point I think better
than Isabel Allende in
her historical novels.
She has written quite a few.
Since the House of the Spirits, it's
been 28 years since that book and--
>> Oh my God, am I old [laughter]?
>> No. You've written 16 books.
All of them--
>> No 18.
>> I'm sorry.
>> 18 books, 17 since
that first one and boy,
I've gotta be really sharp
I'm coming [inaudible].
And every single one of
those books was different.
It seems to me from Eva Luna right
through to Paula, Ines of My Soul
to This Island Beneath the Sea.
Each one is very, very different.
What makes you want to experiment
as you do because every single book
to me is a different experience,
another Isabel Allende is.
>> Well, I wish one
could do the same
with husbands, you know [laughter].
Keep experiencing new husbands
that would be wonderful but,
so I live in my books all the stuff
that I can't live in my real life.
Once I was in a meeting
with librarians.
It was a huge conference
of librarians.
It was mainly middle aged women
with glasses and a little overweight
and one person in the audience
said, the first question was,
are the sex scenes in your books
from real experience [laughter]
and I looked at the audience
and realized I couldn't lie
so I said I wish [laughter].
>> It's just research
and imagination.
So it's the same for the
subject of the books.
I don't know why.
Every story is like a seed inside
and some seeds start to grow
and grow and I think that it's
always related with something
that is really important for me.
It's either a cause or
an idea or an experience
that has a very personal
meaning and then I start writing
without a script and
the story unfolds
and then I don't know
why I'm writing about it.
Why would I write about
an African slave?
Culturally, I'm not close at all.
Physically, she's completely
different from me.
Why would I write about that?
And I think that it has to
do with empowerment of women
and the obsession that I
have always had with freedom
and justice not freedom
in the-- can you hear me?
Not freedom in the, you know,
the big word, internal freedom,
the way that you can have choices
because freedom is about choices
and that has always been
really important for me
and the slaves have none so in this
case, why would I write about this,
because it's an extreme case of
what has always been my obsession
and in all my books, you
would find marginal people
who are not sheltered by the big
umbrella of their establishment,
people who have to overcome huge
obstacles to have a destiny at life.
I'm not interested in suburban
middle class white guys [laughter].
I couldn't write a novel about
Wall Street, about Washington.
I couldn't.
I can write about people who are
outside who are in the margins
of the society for
different reasons, ethnicity
or sometimes a physical
disability or a gender option.
Things like that.
That's what interests me most.
>> You know, you're making me--
you're reminding me that last year
on this very stage, John Irving
was talking and of course,
he has written a lot of books
too and he said in the process
of his presentation that
every single one of the books
that he had written actually was
part of one big book and it seems
to me that that's what
you're saying.
You have created one major opus
really of the women who struggles
against extraordinary odds and
extraordinary adversity and somehow
through love and through
perseverance wins.
Is that true?
>> In a way, it's true but I've also
written a book about a man that goes
through the same circumstances.
Actually, in 1987, I was
passing by California.
I was living in Venezuela
then and I met a guy.
He was introduced to me as
the last heterosexual bachelor
in San Francisco [laughter].
And he started telling
me his life and I said--
he said that he wanted to
write his life and I said,
why don't you let me do it?
I would probably do a
better job and so we spent--
then I went to bed with
him of course [laughter]
because that's how you
get the stories, you know.
Very intimately and I
ended up marrying him
because I needed a list an
American visa [laughter].
I would be married for 23 years
and that's the story of a man
and it's told in the voice of a man.
So it's not always a woman and
then I have a trilogy for kids,
not for kids, for young
adults, that is also told not
from the point of view for woman.
>> I also want to ask you about
your family history which is
such a big part of
your persona in a way.
I think a lot of people have
it wrong I found out by going
into the internet and seeing that
a lot of people actually believe
that you we're the daughter
of Salvador Allende.
You we're actually the daughter
of a cousin of Salvador Allende
but that September 11 which greatly
precedes many, many years ago.
It was 1973 the September 11
that happened ten years ago.
It was dramatically
imprinted on your life and was
in many ways I think perhaps the
impetus because it booted you
out of your own country and made you
an exile for the rest of your life.
Could you tell us a
little bit about that sort
of the political aspect
of your background?
>> Well, I was related
to Salvador Allende.
He has a daughter called Isabel
Allende who is very political and so
when she is asked to sign my
books, she does [laughter].
And when I am told that I was
marching with the communist in Rome,
I said yeah, yeah, I was [laughter].
So why are you going
to explain so much.
She is taller, she has blue eyes and
on September 11th, a Tuesday also
at the same time of the
September 11th here.
In 1973, we had a military coup
which was a terrorist attack
against the democracy.
The strongest and longest
democracy in Latin America in Chile
and it was back by the CIA
by the way and that gave-and
that started a dictatorship
that lasted almost 17 years.
Many people died.
Many people disappeared.
Many people were tortured and many
people left the country either
because they were expelled
and they became exiles
or they chose to leave.
I chose to live.
I couldn't live in terror in my
own country and I went and lived
as a political refugee in Venezuela
for 13 years until I met that guy
in San Francisco [laughter].
So, my life has always been as
a foreigner and I've always felt
that I am not under the big
umbrella of the establishment.
I, of course now, I'm legal
by the way [laughter].
But, I still feel like a foreigner.
I will always look different, always
have an accent and then I go back
to Chile and after a couple of
weeks, I feel foreign there too
because I've changed and the country
has changed and it's hard sometimes.
>> Now, I mentioned before the
fact that you begin every book
on January 8, is this
your sort of rigorous side
or is this your superstitious side?
>> It is both.
I wrote the house of--
I started the House
of The Spirits, my first novel.
I sent a letter to my
grandfather on January 8,
1991 and it was a very lucky book.
This very seldom happens
that a first novel
from a totally unknown person
hits the market and in Europe,
in less than 3 months, it had been
bought by almost every language
in Europe and it became a
huge success immediately.
That paved the way for all my
other books which are not as good
as the first by the way
[laughter] and so I thought,
well, this is a lucky book.
I will start my second book
on a lucky day, January 8th.
And then, I did the same
thing for 3 or 4 books
and then it became a matter of
discipline because my life was very,
very complicated and if I don't
save a few months of the year
without traveling and without any
social activity just lock myself
away to write, I won't
be able to do it.
So now, it's discipline
and superstition.
And by the way, it's Elvis
Presley's birthday [laughter]
which is also a lucky thing.
[ Laughter ]
>> Now, you've been called the most
successful Latin-American female
author in the world.
>> Author.
Not female [laughter].
>> Female author in your own.
[ Laughter ]
>> Why do we have to
make the difference?
[ Applause ]
>> That was going to
be my question to you.
You are the distinction is
really ridiculous, right?
I mean, in fact, Isabel
Allende is, well I know this
because I checked it out, sells
more today in contemporary life
than Cervantes, then Garcia
Marquez, then Carlos Fuentes.
The numbers are there.
Now, that distinction was
exactly what I wanted to ask.
How do you look on the female role
of authors and how and what sort
of struggle do you have to make
that male authors perhaps
don't have to make?
>> Well, any woman has to
be twice as good as any man
to get half the recognition
and respect [applause].
Fortunately, that is not difficult.
[ Laughter ]
>> So [laughs].
So, as a writer, I'm always
called a narrator, a story teller,
a female writer, when
you add an adjective
to the word literature,
you diminish it.
The moment you say
African-American literature
or Latin-American literature
or female literature
or young-adult literature,
it's less.
When it's just literature, it's
white males that are writing.
So, I don't like the distinction.
I think that I use the same
raw material, words and ideas
than any man and I'd write
books that are just as good.
So, I don't want to be separated.
Why would I separate myself?
[ Applause ]
>> I love that.
>> Now, eventually, we're going to
get to questions from the audience
which is really the important part
or this presentation but I had
such fun a few years ago doing
the Proust questionnaire.
Do you know about Proust
questionnaire?
>> Oh, don't do that to me.
Please.
>> Oh. I'm gonna do it [laughs].
>> Please.
>> The Proust questionnaire
which is very, very silly and fun
and all your answers were wonderful.
>> You want me to remember them.
>> No, no.
I want [simultaneous talking]--
>> I'm asking you different
questions this time.
So here we go this is
Proust Questionnaire.
What is your favorite
word in any language?
>> Sex [applause].
It's universal you know,
same with every language.
>> What is the word
you absolutely hate?
>> Violence.
Because of what it means.
>> I'm afraid to ask
you the next question
because I think the answers
gonna be the same as the first.
What turns you on?
>> Chocolate [applause] ha!
And another thing if
someone murmurs in my ear.
You know the only way that
women listen is when you whisper
in their ear and the
G-spot is here [applause].
That turns me on.
>> Ayayay.
What is your idea of hell?
>> Being in a prison, in a cell, in
a closed place where I can't escape
and I have no power over my life.
>> That sounds like a writer's desk.
>> No, because in the writer's desk
you fly, you are with the character,
you are the characters,
you are in the story.
Oh there is-- it's
incredible freedom.
[ Applause ]
>> What is your favorite
hero or heroine in fiction?
>> There are many but I love Zorro.
You know why I love Zorro?
Because Zorro is an action hero
that has no special powers he's
just a guy, a young guy athletic,
humorous, not violent who humiliates
the enemy but doesn't kill
and who just puts on a mask
and fights for justice.
We can all do that, we
can all put on a mask
or not and fight for justice.
We don't need any special powers
and I love the fact that he is,
what do we call him in
Spanish leviano de sangre
with a light blood.
I mean he is funny, he is athletic,
he is young, he is just wonderful.
The lightness of being.
>> Marvelous.
Now who is your favorite
hero or heroine in real life?
>> Actually my mother.
[ Applause ]
>> No comment after that absolutely
and we would all probably
say the same.
What is the quality you
most admire in a writer?
>> The capacity to grab
the reader by the neck
and hold the reader
to the last page.
As a reader I don't want to be
bored, so I can take anything
as long as you keep me interested.
I love the fact that you-- a page
competes with films, with fear,
with music, with things that have
so much vibrancy and elements
and technology and it's just a flat
page with little fly things there
and you get hooked you go in there
and you become part of the story.
A writer that can do
that is a hero to me.
[ Applause ]
>> And she does that.
What is the sound that
you most dread?
>> Actually I think that I remember
very clearly the hawker hunters,
the planes that bombed the palace
in Chile on September 11 and I fear
that very much, the sound of war.
>> Now if heaven exists
and you finally make it
to heaven's door, right.
What would you like to
say when He greets you?
>> Hi! Come in tell me a story.
[ Applause ]
>> Now we're ready to take
your questions so please,
there are two microphones
here and come up.
>> Don't be shy.
>> So here's my question.
What's your process during
the day, you know for writing,
I mean do you have to write
over your garage or do you write
in the morning or do you get
really creative at night.
What's your process
for writing everyday?
>> I get up very early.
I have a wonderful husband
who brings me coffee to bed
and I think that's just such a
wonderful luxury and very early I go
to a little casita that I
have in the back of our garden
where I keep my first editions,
dictionaries, maps, and the research
that I have done for the book
and I just lock myself there
and write all day until
Willie calls me for dinner.
And so I don't know what I'm going
to eat but he has set the table
and he has food on the
table so that's my day.
It is not very interesting but
that's the time when I'm writing.
When I'm not writing then
I can be with the family
and I travel and I do lots of stuff.
But I have to research a lot
so when I'm not writing
I'm reading for my work.
>> Wonderful, thank you very much.
>> What are you reading right now?
>> What am I reading?
Actually I am reading a book by
Azar Nafisi, a memoir of her family.
This is what I started last night.
>> High, this is not working?
>> Yes, it's working.
>> Okay, I've been
following your career
because I'm also a Latin
American woman and I've read all
of your books and it's wonderful
to be able to meet you today,
I'm really honored to be here--
>> Thank you.
>> And I would like to know
what's in the works now?
What can we expect?
What are we-- I've always looked
forward to the next book so--
>> Thank you.
>> You can give us a hint.
>> Well I'm going to take
a sabbatical next year
and do nothing, nothing.
But I already finished
another book just in case.
And I still have to pay the bills
and the book is a very different
book it's a contemporary book.
It happens in 2009 to a young
19-year-old American girl
from California who gets in deep
trouble and then her grandmother
who is Chilean sends her away,
sends her to a very remote island
in the archipelago of
Chiloe in the south of Chile
where life is very rural,
almost medieval and she has
to change all these
technology and all the fuss
and all the noise for
a time of silence.
And what happens in her soul.
>> Hi, I was wondering if you
have read Madison Smartt Bell's
books on--
>> Yes--
>> Haitian revolution and
how if they influenced--
>> Yes, yeah.
okay, Madison Smartt Bell has
written a lot about Haiti.
He has a wonderful trilogy that
is fiction and he has biographies
of Toussaint Louverture
that are extraordinary
and of course I read
them and as I said
when you research you
also read fiction.
You don't read only history books
because other writers
have already researched
and also they have contributed.
So of course it influenced me and
of course I am very grateful to him
and to other writers of
fiction that wrote about slavery
and wrote about-- because not only--
I mean you can find all the
information in the history books
but when you read fiction you're
really getting into everyday life
and that's so interesting.
>> Because also his
writing seems very bloody
>> Wonderful but of course it's very
bloody because Haiti at the time--
I mean-- it was called Saint
Domingue, slaves were expected
to live in the plantations
between 4 and 6 years.
They were exploited to death
with the most horrible
bloody cruel punishments.
So of course it's a
very violent trilogy.
>> Over here, please.
>> I read the La casa de
los spiritus when I was 16
and it changed the direction of my
entire life it was an amazing book
but one of the things that's always
puzzled me is the relationships
oftentimes were abusive but
the woman maintained this love
for their husbands like remaining
in the home even after he hit her
and knocked her teeth out,
she remained in the home,
her spirit remains in the home
looking after him and loving him
and as someone who is such a force
for female empowerment I was
wondering the reasoning behind that?
>> Yeah well if I would
write a book about a husband
who hits his wife today
a contemporary story
of course she would get out of
that relationship but at the time
in the 1900s, 1930, 1940 women
in Chile could not get
out of a relationship.
There was no divorce an
there was no greater scandal
than leaving your husband.
And that's what my mother
did actually, my mother
and my father separated
and my mother was blamed
for it although my father was to
be blamed so the story is placed
at a time when women did not have an
outlet and I think that in the case
of that couple in particular
he adored her,
he was just a very angry man.
And a very unhappy man
but he really adored her,
so that the relationship
is much more complex
than just a violent man
and a submissive wife.
>> My students are reading And
of Clay Are We Created this week
in Missouri and I would
just like to ask,
what is the most difficult
part of the writing process?
>> Of the writing process?
>> Of the writing process.
>> I don't remember that
story did I write it?
>> You did.
>> I did. Oh, it must
have been a long time ago,
and what's the story about?
>> It's a love [inaudible] it's the
girl that's trapped in the basket--
>> Oh, because it has another
name in Spanish, I'm sorry.
>> That's okay.
>> I might-- write in Spanish only,
I can never remember the
titles in another language.
That story is based on a real case.
>> Yes.
>> It's the story of Omayra Sanchez,
a little girl that was trapped
in a mudslide in Colombia and
she lived for three days trapped
in the mud up to here and you could
see in every television in the world
because they flew the
televisions and the press
in you could see her dying for
three days and they could not fly
in a pump to pump the
water and save her life.
So that is a very dramatic
and awful story
and I always have a photograph.
>> In Katrina during Katrina
I thought of your story--
>> Yes and what it takes to write a
story like that I was a journalist
and so I'm aware of the stories
that are always floating in the air,
the extraordinary stories
you get in a car
and someone tells you the story
of her family and it's nine kids
and the father committed suicide
and there is another book, you know.
You just find these
wonderful stories.
Now which story you will write?
It depends on the moment and it
depends on what you are feeling.
In the case of Omayra
Sanchez again it's a story
of person who is trapped.
Who has, who can't escape.
>> I am delighted to
meet you face to face.
>> Thanks.
>> Your books, most recently--
>> Pull up the microphone
I can't hear you.
>> I'm sorry--
>> These tall people, I hate them.
>> I read both in Spanish
and in English
and the three books
I've read most recently,
by you are La isla bajo el mar,
El Zorro, and Ines del alma mia.
I am fascinated by your
creation of characters
who overcome amazing obstacles and
as you mentioned earlier are living
on the margins of society.
I want to zoom in on Zorro.
How was it that you-- what inspired
you to create a story of his youth?
>> Yeah, Zorro was not my idea.
I was one day in summer
of 2003 was it Willie?
2003 these people came to my
house and knocked at the door
and I thought they were Mormon
missionaries so I was prepared
for that but they were really the
owners of the copy write of Zorro.
Zorro has owners.
A family that owns the
rights and they came
and they said we've done everything
with Zorro, we've done movies,
TV series, mugs, costumes,
all kinds of stuff
but we don't have a
work of literature.
Would you like to write
a book about Zorro?
And I said, why me?
And they said because I've
written historical novels,
I'm Spanish originally, I mean
my-- Spanish is my language,
I live in California and I have
written stories for young adults
and so they thought I would be the
perfect person to write the book.
And I said well I don't
write on commission.
But then I thought of Antonio
Banderas in the movies [laughter]
and I thought maybe I will
have a chance to meet him.
So that's why I wrote the book.
>> Thank you.
[Applause ]
>> I just read And of
Clay last year for school
and I got really interested
so I read Eva Luna but--
>> I can't hear you.
You have to get closer
to the microphone.
>> I just read And of Clay last
year for school because I had to
and I got really interested in
your writing and so I read Eva Luna
but I was just curious
because you said you do a lot
of research what's your
favorite genre specifically?
>> What, what's the
research for what?
>> What's your favorite genre
like because if you do a lot
of research you're doing on fiction
so-- but what's your favorite?
>> Well I love to write
historical fiction
because once you research the time
and the place half the book is done.
You have a theater where you
will move the characters.
And I love that kind of book.
It's-- for me it's easier.
Of course the research
can take years
for Island beneath
the sea it was 4 years
in the meantime I write
a memoir but I love
that part of my work, I really do.
>> Okay, that's all.
>> I'm sorry we have just one--
time for one more question.
>> Oh.
>> Okay, the gentleman.
>> The gentleman.
>> The first man--
>> Oh--
>> That stands up an
applause for him.
[ Applause ]
[ Spanish ]
>> Gracias--
>> I hope that one day my Spanish
will be as good as your English.
>> You need to marry a
Spanish woman [laughter].
>> Ah.
>> You learn language
in bed [laughter].
>> Okay. I'll be quick
let's say it's January 7
and if you aren't finishing up a
book from the year before or is it
or you are not taking a sabbatical
what is it are you thinking of ideas
for the book you will
start the next day
or by then you've already begun
the idea or whatever in your head.
>> Well by January 7th I'm
a wreck because I think
that I know what I'm going
to write but I don't--
I am not sure and it has
happened more than once that I sit
with one idea and I end up writing
something totally different.
The only thing I know is that
I will have my casita clean.
I will have taken out everything
that is not related to the book
that I am going to write and
I have all my research ready.
I light candles I put fresh
flowers, I make time, you know.
I procrastinate as much as
possible but then there is a moment
when I have to sit down in front of
the computer and then I breathe in
and breathe out and write
a sentence that comes
from the womb not from the mind.
And that first sentence usually
is like a door that opens
into a dark space that is the
story that I still don't know
and I will go day by day, hour by
hour, word by word investigating
in that darkness until I find
the characters and the story
and it's a very slow process.
The first two or three weeks are
terrible because I am not sure
of what I'm doing and I
have not found the voice.
But once the voice comes, the voice
from the island beneath the sea
is the voice of Zarite, the slave.
When I saw the slave and I heard
her voice, wow, the book was done.
Thank you very much.
>> Muchos gracias.
[ Applause ]
>> Now don't go anywhere
because we are
about to confer the National Book
Festival Creative Achievement Award.
I'd like to introduce Deanna
Marcum who is the Library
of Congress' Associate
Librarian for Library Services.
Deanna.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning everyone.
Isabel, that was absolutely
wonderful thank you
so much it is my great
pleasure to present
to Isabel Allende the Library
of Congress National Book Festival
Creative Achievement Award.
Ms. Allende for your
outstanding contribution
to international letters, for
your involvement in the creation
of the genre magical realism, for
your focus on the struggles of women
and for your plays and children
stories a worldwide audience
has risen.
Ladies and gentlemen please join
me in recognizing Isabel Allende
as the recipient of the
National Book Festival Creative
Achievement Award.
[ Applause ]
>> And now I will sign
all your books.
>> Book signing coming up.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.